what up space fam golson here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story in
this one we got so many hype events
including zorro and king luffy and momo
and much more so make sure to stay tuned
for this one if you do enjoy seeing
these one-piece chapter reviews and want
to keep them coming the best thing you
could do is channel the pirating within
and smash that like button with no mercy
as we all know pirate king smash
orochi's pass if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece videos and while
you wait for the next chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing one
piece playlist that includes videos on
all the anco warlords admirals and most
recently on all the nine mythical zone
users and their powers explained some of
those at least three mythical zones will
probably shock you link to that playlist
is in the description now without
further ado let's jump into its spoilers
and all this chapter is called two p's
in a pod and it starts off at the crazy
point we left off at last chapter where
zoro appeared to cut down king and sanji
hit queen for yet another time that was
probably one of the best one-piece
panels so far love these two working and
fighting together side by side now
they're standing there as the smoke
clears and the two all-stars are down
obviously they're not out because that
would be the most anticlimactic fight
possible for zorro but it's still
significant that kaido's two strongest
have been brought down to the ground by
our very own straw hats as one beast
pirate tries to snipe zorro around the
remaining eye kawamatsu brings him down
my boy hyogoro is here too and he's
adamant about keeping anyone from
interfering with the fight between sanji
zorro and the all-stars he's against
trying to help our guys too because he
knows by the determined and serious
expressions on their faces that they'd
only be getting in the way in the
meantime marco is thinking about a
conversation he had with whitebeard the
late yonko dubbed strongest man alive
even he makes an appearance in this
chapter albeit through memories and
flashbacks while marco commented i
thought only marijuana was above the red
line whitebeard commented that in the
distant past back then god's land was up
there this sounds like some mount
olympus stuff right here but it's
significant because king seems to be
from a nearly extinct race that could
create fire and reside above the red
line so the mystery around king is
really building and i'm sure we'll find
out more during this arc ezo actually
has to help out marco because he's
spaced out on the battlefield but i love
to see how calm marco is as he says i
knew you had my back then as if they're
sitting down for a cup of tea on a lazy
afternoon he asks if ezo believes in god
and ezo comments that he's starting to
sound like pops when he was drunk love
that detail and how marco is starting to
think more like whitebeard while in his
youth he thought whitebeard's talk was
crazy talk but in the myths and legends
there is usually some truth so
dismissing them outright as young marco
did was as we're starting to see not
necessarily the right move as predicted
the winged king and dino queen get up
without issues and queen even says if
they want to take the all-stars down
they gotta try harder because that last
attack didn't hurt at all which is to be
expected but man was that combo attack
ever epic and queen says that the
drought plague and wildfire are kaido's
calamities because of their unstoppable
toughness and that including with jack
seems to be the recurring theme with
them it's not like jack queen and even
king are untouchable people get some
good hits on them but they just keep
coming back up again and again and that
seems to be why they're so dangerous
sanji starts commenting to zorro that
since the second time using the raid
suit he seems kind of off and his body
feels a little odd a detail that's easy
to gloss over but will no doubt be
relevant as this fight progresses let me
know your thoughts on what you think
sanji means and why he's feeling a bit
off king goes in to cut down sanji but
zorro comes to the rescue blocking the
giant sword and telling sanji he owes
him one he doesn't get to have one over
on sanji for long though because sanji
quickly returns the favor by kicking
away queen's attacking arm proclaiming
they're even now queen remembers that
all of judge's brats are enhanced and
sanji's burning leg is an augmentation
sanji answers that he's a regular human
unlike his siblings but queen views this
as an idiotic response saying that what
kind of human can burst into flames it's
not like he's a lunarian which is
defined as an inhabitant of the moon
king looks over suggesting he may be a
lunarian and this is so crazy right now
did sanji actually get augmentations set
in place that he didn't know about that
will let him reach new levels of power
do we finally know king's true race and
will we join enel on the moon sooner
rather than later crazy reveal slash
possibilities jam-packed so close
together and trust me these crazy
reveals are far from over as far as this
chapter is concerned and it gets even
crazier asanji simply shakes off all the
comments saying that the burning is
because his passions burn hotter than
any real flame ever could not super
convincing logically but you do use
sanji with one piece you never know but
it would make more sense to the story if
there was a reason beyond just his
passion that he can just suddenly set
his legs ablaze even without friction
and furthermore survive being on fire
just fine in the meantime queen says his
cybernetic enhancements can't be beat
and that even vegapunk can't match them
huge words considering the weight that
that name carries in the series back to
king and he is not fighting fair in a
swordsman sense but apparently all is
fair in love and war so you can't really
blame him his sword also has special
properties and he is able to use the
jagged edges of it in order to trap two
of zoro's swords and take them away he
then delivers a spiked knuckle sandwich
but zoro manages to block it in pretty
epic fashion with his mouth sword soros
seems to look down on this style of
fighting but king has a point when he
says he never understood why people
stick to traditional forms and
techniques in real battle and zorro
being the boss he is doesn't freak out
but just says yeah you're right you
never claim to be a swordsman as he
grabs his three blades again and
although zoro is more geared towards
that traditional school of swordsmanship
he gets what king is saying and says
that even he zorro may bite through
king's throat because he can't afford to
lose here i love it i love the
commitment i love the fact that he's
willing to do whatever it takes this is
such a great matchup and zorro is
finally gonna be pushed hard so
hopefully we see everything he has to
offer and more post time skip hoping to
see that closed eye activate soon still
expecting something to happen from that
then it's pointed out by hyogoro that
zoro looks exactly like the former
daimyo of ringo when he was young
shimotsuki ushimaru their two p's in a
pod and yes they just said the title in
the chapter the similarity really is
uncanny and it makes sense oda did say
zoro would be from japan in the real
world and juan was definitely the japan
of the one piece world apparently
ushimaru was the direct descendant of
the god of the blade shimotsuki ryuma
and since zoro returned shusui to wano
kawamatsu is convinced it's fate so not
only does luffy have chosen one vibes
zorro definitely does as well he may
well be the direct descendant of this
god of the blade and ryuma it said was a
one-eyed samurai as well the zorro hype
just keeps building and i'm loving it we
then leave the new god of the blade and
catch up with the third disaster jack is
an interesting character and he says he
even forgave his opponent inuarashi for
lying about the samurai his country's
already paid for sheltering him the dude
is 28 years old and he doesn't seem like
a totally evil dude but nevertheless a
dude who will follow kaido's orders
whatever they may be but as we all know
he's always seemed to be the weakest of
the three disasters inuarashi grabs him
by the trunk and throws the giant
creature the dialogue is great too as he
says that everything they went through
since odin left was to get to this point
this is so climactic because we can feel
and have seen in part how long everyone
was preparing for this war and now it's
all happening and they're putting their
all on the line for it and i love to see
the stark contrast of how before jack
was torturing a helpless inuarashi while
now not only did iwarashi just have an
upper hand with the throw he also just
transformed into soo long form so now
jack is really in trouble thanks to the
hole in the roof he looks so amazing and
majestic in his soo long form saying
that although his old city was raised to
the ground the dawn of the world is
finally upon us and all of this dawn of
the world talk definitely makes this
fight in particular feel like an epic we
then jump to perospero who gives pedro
the ultimate compliment by saying
without him luffy and the others
wouldn't have made it here and the raid
would have failed love to see pedro's
actions being shown some love so many
chapters after his death love to see
pedro's actions being shown some love in
the manga so many chapters after his
death pero sparrow is clearly not doing
well he's on the ground and nekomamushi
just entered his soolong form i love it
how he tells pedro to pour a drink while
he promises to take piero sparrow's life
too we see rhizo and fukurokujou's fight
briefly and hilariously enough fuku is
saying that everyone needs time to
mature and that he can't understand how
rhizo is serving a glorified child i say
hilarious because in the next few panels
we see that that maturation has taken
place at least physically thanks to
shinobu obviously there is still the
point to be made that like ryzel said
mentally momo will grow with wano itself
but he definitely looks ready to be a
leader now at least physically when lost
men see momo's dragon form now they
straight up mistaken for kaido it's so
crazy that lil momo now has the same
intimidating presence at least in his
dragon form as kaido not only that he
has a clone of one of the strongest
roots known to man if not the strongest
so his potential is off the charts
obviously it's not all about the fruit
and individuals need to hone their
strength on a personal basis too but
it's still beyond legendary seeing
momo's dragon form with luffy's figures
standing in front of it absolutely
amazing we get a flashback for the full
contrast effect of when momo was still a
tiny dragon who was more bark than bite
and now luffy is excited to see the full
grown dragon he's become as he calls
momo's name with a smile momo says
that's right although he's not an
official member of the straw hats it's
so cool having a kaido looking dragon on
the straw hat side now symbolically this
is cool for
that now they'll be dealing with a good
giant op dragon rather than a drunk bad
one right now momo is physically 28
years old according to shinobu same age
as jack shinobu is crying and it seems
to be because momo now looks like
someone and that someone is most likely
odin imagine how epic it's going to be
when the red scabbards and even kaido
see momo and think it's the return of
odin which it is in a way it's
definitely a return of his will yamato
will probably be all over him too i'm
calling that right now this is the
perfect way to mess with kaido not only
will the dragon form reflect his own but
the human form will reflect his greatest
enemy who still haunts him to this day
then in an epic chills bestowing moment
luffy says let's go take back wano and
momo says yeah and that is the end of
this legendary chapter it was strong
throughout but especially with the zorro
and momo moments my mvp for this one
will be momo zoro was epic too but i'm
sure he'll be more epic in subsequent
chapters and momo's decision to take the
risk and try aging himself in the
subsequent intimidating and epic dragon
form is just too much to not give
respect to this kid had little moments
of greatness here and there but now he
finally looks ready to help take wano
back and he's come so far from the kid
who simply cried before kaido the next
few chapters will no doubt keep this
hype train going as always let me know
what you thought of this chapter what
was your favorite moment and who was
your mvp that's the most important
question if you did enjoy this chapter
review and want to keep the chapter
reviews coming the best thing you can do
is channel the pirate king within and
smash that like button with no mercy
remember pirate king smash or roshi's
pass if you haven't make this the video
you subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my growing one piece playlist
that includes videos on the yonko
warlords admirals and most recently all
nine mythical zone users and their
powers explained as i said some of these
mythical zones will probably shock you
so definitely check that out link to the
playlist is in the description and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you